bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
ports il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
sommaire de cette édition ce week-end
versailles accueillait la 30e édition du
challenge via la compétition nationale
jeunes de hockey sur gazon focus sur
cette discipline où les kobe chinois
font partie des meilleurs en france mais
qui peine à décoller mustapha larbaoui
se succède à lui même l'ex président
démissionnaire de cet hiver des l'étoile
sportive de trappes a repris les rênes
du club il y a quelques jours il
expliquera sa décision sur ce plateau ce
week-end les capoeiristes de
l'association bennoo horizonte
d'elancourt se pliait à la
traditionnelle cérémonie du passage de
grade devant leurs professeurs nous
avons assisté à la fête et évidemment
comme d'habitude en fin d'émission
l'essentiel du week-end mais tout
d'abord place à notre page spéciale
fidèle
ce dimanche 29 juin saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir la deuxième étape
du field day mgen 2014 au bassin de
lasours de riz et pour parler de cet
événement exceptionnel s'est tourné un
petit peu de triathlon à travers la
france la directrice générale du fit
days est accompagné de son directeur de
course corps et carole viala bonsoir à
vous vous êtes accompagné de jean
philippe viala bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être là sur le cette fuite sport
alors première question pour essayer de
rentrer tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet de quoi se compose le fit days
carole alors le fidesz est un événement
qui réunit à la fois les enfants et les
adultes d'abord les enfants de partir de
10h du matin au bassin des sourds de riz
dimanche nous aurons un triathlon
gratuit pour les petits mais aussi des
ateliers éducatifs autour qui traite de
mieux manger mieux bouger mieux
collecter ces déchets savoir sauver une
vie avec les sapeurs-pompiers du 78 donc
voilà tout un programme gratuit pour les
jeunes enfants de 5 à 12 ans on peut
s'inscrire avant peut s'inscrire sur
place on prête entièrement le matériel
on ne les mettra pas dans le bassin de
la sourde oreille puisque nous les
mettons dans une piscine que nous
construisons pour l'occasion voilà en
toute sécurité
c'est très sympa ensuite des seniors
tout et culte il ya évidemment un prix y
attenant de plus grande envergure voilà
un très long distance s est même si
c'est que 750 m de natation cette fois
ci dans le bassin 20 km de vélo et 5 km
de course à pied ça n'en est pas moins
difficile quand même puisque finalement
les distances courtes sont un peu plus
violente en change de rythme très
souvent et c'est plus difficile
finalement qu'on ne pense maintenant ça
permet aussi aux débutantes se lancer
parce que les distances leur font moins
peur et surtout et auront la chance de
courir avec une quinzaine des meilleurs
triathlètes du monde dont le leader de
l'équipe de saint quentin en yvelines
frédéric belaubre qui a été trois
olympiades jean petit pré champion
d'europe et coupe du monde le cv qui
était forcément très longs champs 3d
sera pas seul oui il y aura d'autres
appels de saint-quentin piles et une
équipe allemande je crois ce week end
c'est cette particularité du field day
c'est que un amateur qui
licenciés ou pas peut se confronter aux
meilleurs du monde exactement c'est le
principe et ce sera comme ça pendant
cinq week-ends et c'est ce qui est très
sympa jean-philippe vous êtes le
directeur de course j'imagine que quand
on fait un parcours de triathlon est ce
que on prend en compte justement cet
aspect amateur professionnel pour
essayer de que tout le monde s'y
retrouve c'est un peu novateur c'est pas
forcément évident c'est justement un
challenge qui m'a qui m'a attiré c'est
une sécurité maximale pour avoir des
vitesses très élevées qui seront
pratiqués par les élites mais également
un parcours accessible à tous pour
découvrir triathlon on est sur des
distances le s où l'on peut faire son
premier triathlon sans difficulté
attention l'espèce en vendra
dans la forêt de chevreuse il ya quand
même un petit peu de dénivelé en vélo
après en cours tout à plat autour du
bassin de la sourderie je pense que tout
le monde peut s'y frotter découvrir avec
plaisir cette discipline il ya quelque
chose de surprenant dans ce que vous
dites c'est tout le monde peut s'y
mettre au trias temps alors que le
triathlon et une réputation de sport
difficile carole
centraux d'entraînement peut quand même
y arriver oui parce qu'en fait le
triathlon c'est bon à part les iron man
mais sinon c'est plutôt trois fois moins
que trois fois plus en
répartir la charge dans plusieurs sports
en tout cas physiologiquement on est
beaucoup moins fatigué à l'arrivée d'un
triathlon comme celui là que par exemple
à l'arrivée d'un semi-marathon un
semi-marathon laisse plus de séquelles
que en triathlon distance s donc oui
beaucoup de monde peut se lancer
d'ailleurs on a eu des appels de gens
qui nous disaient ce que je peux je
serai peut-être dans les derniers bains
c'est pas grave il faut toujours un
dernier 1 et puis voilà c'est vraiment
très sympa sur ce parcours ça a été
difficile de le concevoir sur sur 50 ans
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup d espaces
verts mais les circuits de triathlon
vous en parlait il ya des normes de
sécurité comme l'importante les espaces
verts c'est bien c'est surtout l'espace
bleu qui nous faux départ c'est de l'eau
on s'est d'abord interrogé sur la
qualité de de l'eau du bassin la
sonnerie elle est excellente elle permet
la natation dans de bonnes conditions
et ensuite il faut se déplacer dans les
yvelines un dimanche de fin juin et
trouver des itinéraires ou pour une
acceptabilité maximale de la
manifestation on pénalise le moins
possible la vie locale donc on a essayé
de trouver un parcours qui ne gênera pas
trop les automobilistes même si
forcément il y aura quelques fermetures
de routes momentanée et un parcours qui
en même temps permettent d'avoir un
aspect sportif intéressant on y est
arrivé ce dimanche donc 29 juin c'est la
deuxième étape de ce fit days 2014 la
première a eu lieu ce week-end au havre
est remporté par l'équipe de saint
quentin en yvelines
cocorico pour saint-quentin notamment
avec un fred belaubre encore une fois
infatigable je crois qu'il a un rôle
très en forme franchement ça fait des
années que je vois courir fred puisque
je crois qu'il est vu commencé sur un
mais qui dit à l'elfe d'huez il était
encore petit enfant et fred et plus si
jeune que ça il fait il a fait trois
olympiades donc il a hélas proches les
entre 35 et 40 ans je sais plus
exactement mais 35 ans est bon bah il va
très vite parce qu'on était sur une
distance xs au havre avec deux manches
donc encore plus violent encore plus à
la normalement fait pour les très jeunes
triathlètes et il a été exceptionnel
mais il est très rapide il est vraiment
beau à voir courir il n'y a pas que lui
il ya un garçon qui s'appelle aymeric
peut-elle qui est vraiment d'ici en plus
son papa et le le manager du club du
club et aymeric n'a pas fait loin de
wilfred il est plus jeune mais il a fini
3e et puis dans un temps très très bon
tu dois aussi un chouette athlètes voilà
vous parliez des du côté enfant le kid
justement c'est aussi l'autre partie du
fit days il y à des ateliers de
sensibilisation à différentes à
différents domaines notamment et que les
sapeurs-pompiers sur sur cet événement
l'objectif aussi c'est d'amener le plus
possible d'enfants à la discipline oui
là l'an dernier il ya eu près de 10%
d'enfants qui ont pris des licences à la
suite du kid c'est un événement qui leur
donne l'envié je crois que c'est un
sport qu'ils aiment beaucoup parce que
si on leur parle de faire que la
natation que du vélo que de courir
poussée des sports un peu anciens mais
le triathlon s'est enchaîné on zappe
c'est moderne c'est l'an 2000 il adore
ça et finalement ça mon petit piège pour
les ramener vers les sports d'endurance
le triathlon c'est un petit peu l'école
de la vie je sais que vous aimez bien
dire cette formule oui parce qu'en fait
on leur apprend tout il faut apprendre à
mettre un casque il faut apprendre à
lacer ses chaussures
finalement ils apprennent plein de
choses avec nous ils sont surtout
motivés en sortant de là pour apprendre
à bien nager parce que on en tire au
sort on en tirera au sort 14 à 50 1
dimanche qui vont les représenter leur
ville dans une finale régionale parce
que le jour j ils ne vont pas être
chronométrés ils vont tous être
récompensés vont tous partir avec le
t-shirt le bonnet de bain le gilet de
sécurité la petite médaille le petit
goûter par contre 14 qui finalement
représenteront saint quentin en yvelines
dans une finale régionale
alors on la perd finalement la super
finale puisque là cette fois ci ont
déclenché ces chronos envoie en
superfinale envie 48 heures avec en plus
les pros qui sont avec eux et ça c'est
un super souvenir pour les enfants au
delà de la rigueur il ya aussi peut-être
l'aspect santé du sport dont on nous
vante énormément les vertus mais c'est
vrai que dans le triathlon on s'y
retrouve beaucoup on s'y retrouve c'est
un sport d'équilibré qui les athlètes
sans jamais blesser tout travail ce que
je disais tout à l'heure plutôt trois
fois moins qu'à trois fois plus
puisqu'il répartissent la charge de
travail dans les trois disciplines et
donc finalement ils sont moins baissés
aux genoux qu'un cycliste ou moins
blessé aux épaules qu'un nageur et c'est
excellent pour la santé oui oui pour le
développement du coeur ça a été prouvé
les médecins disent que c'est un sport
excellent il faut pas en avoir peur il
avait démarré avec des images très dures
dans les années 80 on n'est plus du tout
là dedans en a 500 école de triathlon
évolue ça a totalement isolées très bien
donc si vous voulez évidemment essayer
pour vos enfants le triathlon c'est ce
dimanche au bassin de la souris à partir
de 10 heures jusqu'à 18h et puis pour le
grand rendez-vous des seniors sur les
coups de midi et 12h30 rue pour patron
mettez les circulations rémy un truc
merci beaucoup à tous les êtres passé
sur les études sport et donc on suivra
ça de près ce dimanche ce week-end le
site de la boulie à versailles
accueillait la 30e édition du challenge
via la compétition nationale jeunes de
hockey sur gazon discipline où les clubs
l'événement font partie des meilleurs du
pays mais ce sport de crosse peine à
décoller reportages réalisés avec
patrick jacques de dixmude et yolaine
torres
rené deux équipes de six à onze joueurs
armés d'une crosse un terrain de plus de
90 m 2 et une balle et vous avez un
match de hockey sur gazon mélangeant
geste de tennis de football et de gaulle
qu'est-ce qu'il ferait ce sport d'équipé
on passe tout le temps la balle chacun
c'est beau à voir aussi ce que j'aime
bien regarder les matchs tous les
matchs l'équipe première si les yvelines
compte deux des meilleurs clubs français
avec le racing et le champion de france
saint germain en laye la discipline
pourtant olympique reste encore méconnu
avec environ 17000 pratiquants en france
au racing on souhaite donc se tourner
vers les écoles pour recruter et avec un
argument de poids on a besoin de
dextérité on a un outil dans les mains
qui est une crosse est pareil on a
besoin de beaucoup de motricité entre la
crasse dans les mains
courir avec cette instance il met tout
en regardant un peu ses coéquipiers pour
faire des bonnes passes donc on les
enfants c'est plutôt un très beau sport
pour passer un cap un club comme le
racing tente d'attirer d'importants
sponsors mais face à des disciplines
populaires comme le football le combat
s'annonce très compliquée c'est un
cercle on essaie de mettre en place qui
est pas simple puisque vous avez certes
un sport qui prennent 80 voire 90 % de
l'audience médiatique et nous l'objectif
effectivement c'est d'imaginer pourquoi
pas un rapprochement avec d'autres
sports avec d'autres sections pas
suffisamment médiatisé pour créer du
contenu mutualisés à l'heure actuelle le
hockey est l'un des trois sports les
plus médiatisés au monde
ce week-end lille accueillait la finale
du championnat de france une finale 100%
yvelinoise entre le racing et saint
germain en laye et c'est saint germain
qui s'est imposé 4 buts à 1 et décroche
là son sixième titre en neuf ans les
deux clubs sont d'ailleurs qualifiés
pour la coupe d'europe de hockey qui
débutera en octobre prochain allez on
passe à notre entretien football
le 10 février dernier sur ce plateau
vous annonciez votre démission mustapha
vous vous retiriez de la présidence de
l'étoile sportive de trappes et bien il
ya une semaine à peu près vous avez été
réélu à la tête du club de football
trappistes bonsoir à vous merci d'être
là sur le site du sport encore une fois
pour un nouveau match comme on soit on
s'était dit c'était que c'était le
dernier match en février finalement vous
êtes réélu c'est quoi c'est un retour
aux sources pour vous cette réélection
d'abord je tiens à dire que depuis que
je suis président du de l'étoile
sportive de train pas je démissionne
tous les ans donc ça se sache quand même
donc je m'accroche pas à mon siège en
disant je suis là pour des années et
personne prendre à mon siège pour le
coup je démissionne tous les ans et
joliesse de son idylle tous les ans tous
les ans c'est une remise en question
c'est en tout cas je laisse le soin aux
adhérents de me reconduire ou pas donc
ça c'est une première chose semaine donc
c'est pas extraordinaire non plus là
pour le coup ce qui est ce qui est
différent ce qui change pour cette fois
ci c'est que voilà vous retirer vous
retirez un instrument de travail à qui
que ce soit il peut pas travailler là en
l'occurence j'avais vraiment le
sentiment qu'on voulait pas me laisser
travailler et donc je voyais pas comment
je pouvais continuer donc je me suis
arrêté tout naturellement disons je ne
peux pas travailler et je ne réclame
rien d'autre que le soin qu'on puisse me
laisser à vouloir travailler ça on l'a
bien compris puisque évidemment on avait
laissé supposer sur ce plateau une
possible candidature aux élections
évidemment et vous n'avez pas été
présent sur aucune liste municipale
alors cinq mois 4 4 5 mois après
on ne pensait pas vous retrouver à la
tête du club vous aviez l'impression
vous donniez en tout cas l'impression
d'être arrivé à saturation
vous avez retrouvé l'énergie l'envi de
vous battre pour les pôles sportifs de
trappes ainsi j'ai donné ce sentiment je
m'en excuse parce que c'est pas vrai je
suis jamais jamais à saturation surtout
quand on fait pour le coup quand on est
engagé dans un mouvement extrêmement
passionnant qui est le sport en général
on a entendu des gens parler de leur
sport tout à l'heure on voyait bien que
ça ça pétille est et qui sont cola avec
beaucoup de d'entrain moi c'est pareil
donc si j'ai des sentiments c'est
peut-être parce que j'étais un petit peu
fatigué un peu las et de répéter les
mêmes choses c'est à dire que 9 113
licenciés avec trois terrains de foot
quand il y en a pratiquement le double
de terrain ailleurs avait pratiquement
que la moitié des adhérents tout le
monde en a fait le calcul que c'était
pratiquement 1 faisable donc voilà donc
cette somme seulement pour sa suite à
votre démission il a eu plusieurs
manifestations dans la ville d les
maraudes de joueurs des jeunes joueurs
est ce que justement c'était pour
réclamer un terrain on va dire
praticable la mairie selon nos sources a
pu visiter ses installations
elle a cédé du terrain justement sur ce
domaine c'est un joli jeu de mots
effectivement ils ont alors on n'a pas
dire qu'ils ont cédé du terrain mais au
moins ils ont convenu qu'il y avait une
nécessité d'avoir un terrain
supplémentaire voilà en l'occurrence
comment ça je le dirai ici c'est pas ma
méthode de réclamer violemment puisque
je les réclames et calmement simplement
ça ne venait pas donc je me suis mis à
l'écart j'ai préféré démissionner c'est
vrai que le terrain s'est mobilisée en
disant on est avec notre président on a
besoin d'un terrain de foot pour
travailler les enfants ne sont pas à
mettre dans la rue mais dans les
terrains de foot on a été entendue sur
ce sujet j'ai rencontré le nouvel
adjoint chargé des sports il m'a
confirmé à la dernière assemblée
générale le député était l'adjoint aux
sports était là le maire de trappes là
l'adie également voilà je pense qu'on a
été entendu mon a été entendu encore une
fois sur des revendications très noble
celle de vouloir travailler tout
simplement si c'était à refaire vous
démissionnez riez à nouveau pour garder
gagner des terrains praticables pour
l'avenir alors je les ai pas fait pour
ça je les fais parce que je ne peux pas
travailler maintenant je me rends compte
qu'effectivement on à la préserver ça a
beaucoup servi je déplore la méthode ça
n'a jamais été la mienne et ça ne le
sera pas pour autant dans les prochaines
années j'aimerais simplement qu'on se
retrouve plus facilement autour d'une
table ce qui n'a pas été le cas j'ai pas
pu me retrouver réellement autour d'une
table ça a pris des proportions
alors le contexte politique a voulu qu
effectivement ça soit plus voilà dans un
contexte très paranoïaque
c'était pas c'était pas ma façon dont on
est quand même ça sparano nous les gens
à lire âgées pas des journalistes
j'en ai lu ce que vaut votre démission a
fait des émules on sait qu'à versailles
ça a beaucoup bougé est-ce que vous
pouvez comprendre la réaction de
certains licenciés aux parents de
joueurs qui disent bas le président s'en
va il revient trois mois après qu'est ce
qui fait à babu toutes les questions
sont légitimes encore une fois je leur
dis à ces gens qui sont posé la question
je démissionne tous les ans donc je
remets en question mon statut maintenant
là cette fois ci je suis parti parce que
je ne peux pas travailler mais c'est
dans l'intérêt de leurs enfants si je
peux pas travailler c'est pas moi
techniquement qui jouent au foot c'est
bien dans leur intérêt donc la question
qui se pose c'est il part y revient bon
bah je suis désolé je présente mes
excuses à la télévision pour avoir
dramatisé peut-être le sujet simplement
c'était dans l'intérêt encore une fois
de vouloir rester à travailler donc oui
bien sûr je peux comprendre bien sûr on
va parler du plan sportif et des
résultats parce que en tant que
président vous êtes évidemment
responsable du côté sportif l'équipe
première après avoir lutté pendant
longtemps vous êtes venu sur ce plateau
avant des chocs contre nanterre pour la
pour la première place en promotion
d'honneur a fini à une anonyme 7e place
on a l'impression qui a certaines
équipes suite justement peut-être à
votre départ qui ont fini en eau libre
un petit peu cette saison ce qui est
important dans ce que vous dites c'est
qu'effectivement quand ça va mal à la
tête ça va mal dans les jambes et dans
un club c'est pareil lorsque le bureau
est atteint on voit bien les joueurs sur
le terrain on le voit pour d'autres
clubs même saint quentinois il ya un
problème à la tête on le retrouve au
niveau des joueurs ça c'est une réalité
simplement il ya aussi une autre réalité
c'est la psychologie quasiment de deux
de nos joueurs et notre équipe c'est je
suis premier où je fais rien ces voix là
et quand on a décroché contre trappe
entre dentaire
j'ai voulu maintenir au moins la
deuxième place au passage la deuxième
place a permis à noisy d'être
sélectionné en tant que meilleur
deuxième chose qu'on aurait pu faire si
on était resté deuxième faire sachant
qu'on a battu noisy aller retour donc il
ya eu effectivement malheureusement on
s'est laissé aller alors oui
cette histoire de démission et tout ce
qui s'en est suivi a pu troubler
simplement en progression un prétexte
non plus un peu trop facile ces premiers
ou rien on sait on doit tenir notre rang
et si notre en c2 ça sera deux mais
notre tenue en entrant on va se projeter
sur la prochaine saison puisque vous
continuez à être évidemment le président
en étoile sportive de travaux prochain
chantier qu'elles vont quel monde il est
alors pour le coup le prochain terrain
de foot le synthétique c'est un chantier
important on va le suivre et sinon
très très très belle
comment dire très beau cadeau fait par
les gens de trappes beaucoup reviennent
c'est une saison on est vraiment on sent
qu'on est vraiment un tournant il ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui viennent il y
aura des surprises de joies de très très
très très haut niveau et de très hauts
talons ouais je prends des rangs compris
rahm a été sérieux que ça fait dix ans
qu'on mène un combat et qu'on travaille
et on en est récompensé que des retours
donc on a vraiment pour le coup un vrai
défi à relever celui de faire en sorte
que ceux qui sont revenus et ceux qui
demeurent et qui veulent rester dans
soit jamais déçu une dernière question
évidemment c'est la coupe du monde je
sais que vous la suivez avec beaucoup de
passion que pensez vous de ces
performances de l'équipe de france qui
bat qui rayonne sur cette phase de
poules alors c'est juste un bonheur
j'étais sur ce plateau ont parlé de deux
fois précédentes mais j'étais sur ce
plateau pour dire que je voyez bien
l'équipe de france qualifiée en battant
l'ukraine j étais au stade et on avait
gagné 3 0 là j'ai vraiment le sentiment
qu'il ya un boulevard on l'a vu contre
cette équipe suisse a été vraiment une
explosion de buts mais en même temps de
talent et puis on sent bien que si comme
cette équipe de france en europe c'est
un peu facilement dans les demi finales
sont en demi finale merci beaucoup
monsieur la fin très bientôt c'est sur
les études sport pour de nouvelles
aventures sans transition pour passe à
la capoeira et pour leur dernier
rassemblement de la saison les
capoeiristes de l'association belo
horizonte d'elancourt se pliait à la
traditionnelle cérémonie de passage de
grade devant leurs professeurs en
portage réalisé avec patrick jacq
d'habitude ils forment un cercle
comme pour ne pas rater la fête un par
un les jeunes capoeiristes joue avec
l'un des professeurs l'objectif être
intronisé dans le monde de la capoeira
est passé son grade
si on le fait c'est parce qu'on est moi
et donc le vase et je gratte ça montre
que on évolue en fait
les limiers possible votre les bêtes
pour recevoir une nouvelle corde
l'équivalent des ceintures au judo
chaque élève doit réaliser une
compilation rythme et des mouvements
appris pendant l'année coup de pied
enchaînements acrobatiques esquive et
déplacement au sol sans grade et il ya
des choses qui vont tenter en fait dans
le passage de grade à ces cantons et qui
allonge
après il ya les instruments après ya
l'apprentissage de la langue brésilienne
l'histoire de la capoeira et de l'
esclavage cette cérémonie traditionnelle
appelée baptême tire ses racines il ya
plusieurs siècles à l'époque où la
capoeira était interdite et pratiques et
qu'on destine mans pourchassés par la
police les capoeiristes avait des
surnoms pour ne pas être dénoncés
désormais ces jeunes peuvent danser
librement et nul doute qu'ils tenteront
d'accrocher de nouvelles couleurs à leur
taille l'année prochaine
allez on passe aux résultats du week-end
tout d'abord en baseball pour le compte
de la 9e journée du championnat de
division 2 montigny recevait la lanterne
rouge dunkerque et les cougars se sont
imposés très tranquillement ce week-end
10 à 0 et 12 à 2 avec cette douzième
victoire de la saison montini conforte
sa deuxième place devant le pôle fédéral
et à trois succès du leader la rochelle
ils peuvent désormais préparer
sereinement les playoffs qui auront lieu
à partir de la fin août en football les
u 13 de l'usb en cours que dont les
responsables étaient venus sur le
plateau ont participé vous le savez il
ya quelques semaines à la finale
nationale du challenge henri guérin
l'équivalent de la coupe de france de
football pour la catégorie moins de 13
ans 6 matches ont permis à ces jeunes
joueurs de se confronter aux meilleures
équipes de france après une victoire 1 0
face à vannes 2 nuls et 3 défaites ils
ont terminé à une honorable 18e place au
général au classement final si c'est
strasbourg qui l'emportent guyancourt a
décroché le prix du fair-play nationale
en basket c'est officiel nous vous
l'annoncions il ya quelques semaines fin
mai tout précisément après une
parenthèse d'un an et une relégation en
nationale 2 féminine de basket
l'entraîneur vinko berdych fait son
retour sur le banc de l'entente le
chesnay versailles
il sera assisté de julie femmes et on
l'on connaît déjà le nom de trois
nouvelles joueuses le expérimenté pivot
lituanienne à augustine a dit gâtés et
en primes prime à la jeunesse avec deux
jeux charles dickens et marine bourreau
tous deux âgés de moins de 20 ans on
suit évidemment nos deux rameurs qui
réalise la traversée du pacifique
après quatorze jours de cours sur la
great pacific reis christophe papillon
et clément et lieu originel de millemont
dans les yvelines continuent leur
traversée de l'océan pacifique à la rame
ils maintiennent leur cinquième position
au classement général derrière quatre
équipages de compos composé de 80 meur
et il mène la flotte des bateaux avec
deux rameurs au milieu des vagues de
l'océan pacifique ils ont failli
chavirer à plusieurs reprises cette
semaine mais il arrive à maintenir un
cycle de deux heures de rame deux heures
de sommeil je vous le rappelle leur
challenge est gigantesque
puisqu'ils doivent relier à la rame et
sans escale la californie a while soit
environ à vol d'oiseau 3900 km à l'est
avant de se quitter on passe à l'agenda
de votre week-end tout d'abord il y aura
du vtt avec la 15e éditions de la
revanche art sur la colline d'elancourt
point culminant d'ile-de-france à 2 131
mètres d'altitude avec en bonus une
démonstration de handbike départ de
cette revancharde à 9h15 ce dimanche 29
juin il y aura du rugby tournoi
international de 7,2 coeur chaque équipe
inscrite doit collecter un minimum de
800 euros pour participer alors à
l'organisation de ce tournoi et des
sommes qui seront reversés au profit de
diverses associations tout le week-end
28 et 29 juin prochains
c'est la fin de ce set 8 fort merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine mais mieux même heure d'ici là
une excellente soirée sur tv fille